[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Juliette riaño
[Música]
la inestabilidad política en Sudán que
derivó en un conflicto interno entre el
ejército regular y los paramilitares de
las fuerzas de apoyo rápido deja en el
medio a miles de desplazados internos
nuevos refugiados y otros tantos
retornados a países inseguros según
Naciones Unidas al menos 860000 personas
cruzarían las fronteras para huir de la
guerra y la mayoría llegarían a Egipto y
sudando el sur en este programa veremos
Cuál es la situación de los refugiados y
retornados en ambas naciones regime es
un artista sudanés ahora refugiado en El
Cairo su historia a continuación
estaba en El Cairo Cuando comenzó el
conflicto en Sudán el apartamento que
alquiló para sus vacaciones se convirtió
en un refugio este galerista su danés
acogió aquí a su hermana niama que llegó
de jartum embarazada de ocho meses junto
a sus dos hijos Tamara y mustafa niama
huyó de los combates
los primeros días tuvimos que quedarnos
en el suelo cuando había disparos no fue
solo la guerra los tiroteos y las
matanzas Me costó mucho reunir el coraje
para llevarme a mis hijos y salir de
allí el día que llegué fue la primera
vez que pude dormir más de dos horas
seguidas Durante un mes entero no pude
dormir al igual que ni ama más de
175.000 sudaneses han oído a Egipto por
lo que la agencia de la ONU para los
refugiados advierte una crisis
humanitaria
su situación requiere atención urgente
varias personas viven en la misma
vivienda muchos niños tuvieron que
abandonar la escuela Y todavía hay
personas que están en estado y no
entienden lo que pasó desde el Cairo
rajim Está tratando de ayudar a los
artistas en Sudán a organizar una
campaña de financiación colectiva
mientras sus obras están atrapadas en
una galería en jartum él trata de
adaptarse y aceptar su nuevo estatus
nunca pensé que algún día estaría en
esta situación absolutamente no nunca lo
imaginé
ahora que lo estoy viviendo me doy
cuenta que estaba lejos de entender por
lo que están pasando mis amigos que
huyeron de sus países de origen pensé
que los entendía pero no lo hice
claramente ese no fue el caso
al igual que ni ama y rahim miles de
sudaneses se han visto obligados a salir
hacia un país vecino sin saber si algún
día volverán a casa la violencia de
ciudadano obliga también al
desplazamiento de quienes ya lo habían
hecho decenas de miles de Sur sudaneses
que buscaron protección Allí se ven
obligados a regresar a su país Pese a
que no es un lugar seguro y las
difíciles condiciones de ese tránsito
hacia el retorno empeoran más su
situación esto pasa en Reik una de las
zonas fronterizas de mayor circulación
de vuelta a un país del que huyeron
cuando comenzaron los combates en Sudán
los zursudaneses que buscaron Refugio
Allí se vieron envueltos nuevamente en
un conflicto del que eran ajenos cruzar
a su país era la única opción
la situación de mi familia en jartum era
desesperada salimos corriendo de allí
porque la situación es muy mala no hay
agua no hay electricidad y hasta no hay
comida porque no hay trabajo por eso
hacemos un llamado a nuestros familiares
que son parte de la diáspora y a nuestro
gobierno para que nos apoyen y traigan a
los que se quedan atrás de vuelta a casa
en ese tránsito hacia el retorno llevan
semanas en este campamento que está al
límite ante la llegada de más y más
compatriotas
llevo 45 días Aquí el ambiente está
lleno de moscas serpientes y no hay
buena comida nuestros niños no están
acostumbrados al tipo de comida que se
les da aquí y algunos tienen diarrea y
los últimos días hemos perdido a tres
niños en este campamento el ambiente es
muy malo los organismos de ayuda alertan
sobre las necesidades urgentes para la
atención de los repatriados en un país
donde dos tercios de la población
dependen de la asistencia humanitaria
para sobrevivir
este lugar no tiene la capacidad
suficiente para atender a la gente y con
la temporada de lluvias Podemos esperar
muchos problemas incluidas enfermedades
como el cólera por el ambiente
deficiente y también por los niveles de
desnutrición es necesario obtener fondos
y brindar los servicios necesarios en
los establecimientos de salud la agencia
de la ONU para los refugiados reporta
que más de 100.000 personas cruzaron las
fronteras de Sudán hacia Sudán del sur
unas mil por día los que retornan llegan
a un país sumido en múltiples crisis una
guerra civil la hambruna y los efectos
de los desastres naturales
de los más de 860.000 desplazados que
dejaría el conflicto en Sudán se estima
que unos 580,000 ciudadaneses
abandonarían su país y al menos
235.000 refugiados que fueron acogidos
en Sudán se verían obligados al retorno
y el dato de migración de la semana
después de tres años de cierre el museo
de la historia de la migración reabre en
París la apertura estará acompañada de
una colección permanente que responde a
como los inmigrantes dieron forma a la
sociedad francesa su directora recuerda
que en la actualidad uno de cada tres
franceses o es inmigrante o tiene raíces
extranjeras
hasta que migrantes de France 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrante f24
sigan con más información en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]